okay
a bit slow on that one
okay
all right this is just bishop d5
watch and we refresh this position
but it's all right
don't think i'm beating any records here
today oh the farm
that's white
amazing
i wonder what about my time
so yeah am i going to beat any records
i likely know okay let's give a check
first and then we think
so what now queen g6
i don't think i'm going to beat any
records here
but who knows
well i mean okay there's bishop g6 for
sure i can get six okay if queen g6
right he runs like two
g8 back and i don't think like i shoot
something
all right okay of course here's bishop
95 i'm just stupid
might be three
there's no defense against mate
nice
uh okay i think i had
a very similar position in my game with
the same idea
nice
i think i see it
mini six
let's take a night screen e6 and then
maybe someone okay we have five uh we
should deliver mate quickly with checks
so what's here okay queen queen h is
known so probably queen e6 oh there is
also
there's also we should be seven which
makes some sense can be seven and b7
king is sick brain is six which should
be sixteen c four would be five okay
there are no more checks
aha so this is this is the way i think
yeah
and this is the way
again sort of a stupid position because
every single move wins
oh alternative so just rick p2 okay
because like the immediate
d7 was more forcing there
all right so this is probably d7 and
rook b2 or which immediately or we're
going to immediately play with g2 and
you prolong your suffering game but we
should stop it
as far as soon as possible
well again d7
no
seriously
okay you know if you want me to play
rugby 2 probably but it's i mean all the
same the 7 is just to a similar position
i think it's kind of wrong
rookie 6.
g7 rookie eight
all right what's this
we need
a glorious knight to jump
probably okay there is rookie six
strokes idea as well yeah rv6 and then
we should play g7
yeah i think it's
nice are we loading overloading
marshall oh this one is quite famous
okay but this is this reminds me of cod
of haberbach
okay let's just i don't know let's just
sacrifice all the things and animate
nothing more smetan that is
that's awesome
credit three right
it's got to be
made that's a simple one
okay this looks like very simple
what if queen e3 takes rook b2 b3 i
think that's that's correct
very pleasing
very pleasing indeed
yeah everything wins obviously
i guess you just take
h3 and this is the cleanest
so the next one uh we need to work okay
whatever should be five
and uh i'm going to resign here or or
not yet
okay like can i destroy at least
and at least this one should work
character 2 is meeting
here queen e1 bishop and queen h4 is
mate
rook
f7 queen h4
queen e1
bishop d4 queen h4 mates